hello everyone it's really nice to be
here and I guess it has been a long day
so I'll try not to talk to you too much
so I'm I'm used or used tonight as my
full name and I'm a developer advocate
at rasa rasa is a
berlin-based startup which is working on
open source conversational AI software
so software that can be used to build
chat BOTS so if your company or you
yourself want to build your own Siri you
can definitely use rather for that and
today I'm going to look into how to
build a chat bot using machine learning
so yeah okay so some motivation of why
would you use machine learning and in
general why would you want to build chat
BOTS so chat BOTS are already around and
they are changing the way we interact
with apps the way we interact with the
software and it basically simplifies
tasks which are occupying too much of
our time so that we can focus on other
tasks and our daily lives so for example
here I have an example where a user
moves to another city and there are so
many things that you have to take care
of when you do that and one of them of
course changing an address and a child
would like this I can do this operation
and the user can change their address
just by using their smart phone or their
laptop but of course when you build
child was you have to keep in mind a few
things that choppers have to be scalable
and in this example here that I have you
can see that sometimes a childhood is
not picking the right information that a
user is providing so it is important to
build child BOTS which can adjust and
kind of fix themselves and also there
are so many different ways how users can
ask the same questions and it is of
course very important to build chat BOTS
which can handle conversations like that
they wouldn't follow one specific
path and that they would be able to
adjust to so many different ways of
interacting with them so what is rasa as
I mentioned rather the companies working
on software for conversational AI and
the main software stack that was
developing is called rasa stack which
developed the consists of two
open-source libraries rasa and aloo and
rasa core and they are open source so
anyone can use them and hug them and
rasa NW is a library for natural
language understanding so you would use
this type of library to teach your child
to understand what a user is saying so
what they mean by asking questions are
saying specific things and rasa core is
a library for dialogue management so
when a child learns to understand what
the users say they have to learn to
respond so rasa core uses machine
learning to predict what action a child
should make at specific state of the
conversation and it's all based on
machine learning and that's why it
learns from the data so that I know kind
of predefined rules or like happy path
that a users have to follow but we will
look into it in more detail quite soon
so okay so this is the overview of how
the stack works on high-level so let's
say a user has a question like what's
the weather like tomorrow and the first
stage that this message would go through
is a connector so it is some kind of
interface for example it can be a
messenger or telegram or slack or your
own custom UI that you developed so
basically an interface that message
comes in through and then the smashes
goes through input module so called ears
and this is where ossa n lu comes in
play it takes that message it extracts
structured data from input sentence
and helps travel to understand what the
user asked for example in this specific
example what's the weather like tomorrow
a child would understand that the user
asked for weather forecast and it will
probably understand that a user wants to
see the weather forecast for tomorrow
specifically so when it gets all these
details out of unstructured user data
they all go to dialogue management
so-called brain so this is Roszak or at
a stage where child takes all these
extracted pieces of information and some
other bits and predict how a child
should respond so responses can be
different things it can be just like
simple text responses or you can also
connect a child to some kind of back-end
so for example retrieve data from a
database or make API calls and use that
extracted information as responses it's
your user and then of course you need an
output module a mouth for your childhood
so someone has to respond and there are
also different ways how we can do that
so you can either use as in mazik or
templates of how a child would respond
in specific situation or you some kind
of natural language generation and then
of course a message should go back to a
user on the same interface as it was
provided so it goes back to a connector
so a messenger or anything else you are
using
and so response can be it will be sunny
and 20 degrees Celsius okay so of course
there are alternatives and you probably
heard of some of them so for example
dialogue flow which is which belongs to
Google or with dot ai or or Lewis dot a
I but they are hosted solutions and Raza
is as I mentioned as open source and
probably for now like the main start
which is leading open source
conversational ai
software out there um so why would you
use Raza and not some kind of hosted
solution as I hope so so first of all
Raza
runs locally and you can build chat BOTS
who runs on your local machine and you
don't have to host it on a specific
platform if you prefer you can host your
chat BOTS on on the cloud on your prefer
the server or like basically whatever
you want there are no restrictions for
that another point is that you own your
data so that means that the training
data you are using it belongs to you you
don't have to provide it to some kind of
specific company that will maybe later
use it themselves and it's very
important especially for enterprise
companies because sometimes the data
you're working on is very sensitive you
can't really disclose it so with Raza
you own data for yourself and since his
open-source is hackable so you can build
things on top of Raza you can use your
own preferred models you can tune them
to adjust to your own domain and make
changes and just basically have fun with
it and make improvements the way you
want okay so what this session is going
to be about so as I mentioned we are
going to look into how I can use machine
learning to build chat BOTS and the
roadmap for this session is going to be
first we are going to take a look at
natural language understanding so
Razzano you and a little bit under the
hood like what's happening and how
information is expected from user inputs
then we're going to do a little bit of
coding then we will look into that our
handling and all the pieces that goes
there and as well we will do coding as
well we will develop a dialogue
management model and I will mention a
little bit about the research that far
working on and I think there will be
some time for questions as well but if
you have some burning questions
throughout the talk definitely raise
your hand and feel free to ask okay so
for this session I'm going to use
Jupiter notebooks and I have shared a
link to those Jupiter notebooks on slack
so if you saw that and they had a chance
to got those data from the repository
which is written here that's great but
you have time to get it right now
because I'll talk a little bit about NLU
so and the link will be in subsequent
slides as well so don't feel rushed to
memorize it super quickly okay
so I will start with Raza NLU and how it
works and what is under the hood and
again there is a link to the github
repository so if you want so as I
mentioned Rosanna U is a open source
framework for natural language
understanding and the main idea is that
it takes unstructured user data any type
of text input and extracts structured
data in the world of Raza NLU the
structured data consists of two main
things so it is intent which is an
intention of what a user is speaking
about or what it is asking and entities
entities are the pieces of information
from this unstructured data that would
help a child to make more specific
answers so for example right here so the
same change-of-address example and a
user said I have a new address and it's
the specific in San Francisco so a child
should understand that the intention of
this input is change address change so
as you can see the intent and also what
are the details that will help a child
make more specific action or more
specific respond
so this is for example an address that a
user already has so that when a child
knows where a user lives from now on it
will be a lot easier for a child to just
go and make specific action using that
address so the goal was basically to
extract those two parts of information
entities and intent so how does it work
so again I have some high-level overview
and when a user for example asks what's
the weather like tomorrow it goes
through natural language understanding
stage and basically what happens is that
it goes to a vectorization stage we
would tokenize each word in this input
sentence into tokens and we would look
up word vector for each of the words and
then we would use word vectors to create
representations of the sentence which
are then going to be used to train the
model and it is a classification problem
and when we have an input what's the
weather like tomorrow a result of this
classification problem would be request
weather for example so how that works so
this is one of the examples of how it
can be done so when you have an input
like what's the weather like tomorrow as
I said you have two tokenize each not
like you have to browse on aleut
organizes each word into tokens and then
a vector word vector is looked up for
each of the words and by taking an
average of all those vectors for each
word we create a representation for the
sentence and that sentence
representation alongside the label is
going to use to train the model which in
this case is
svm and for a test input so for example
something like that's what the world
like tomorrow it will go through the
same stage and the result of a
classification would be one of those
five labels so is it greed is it goodbye
thank you as weather all confirmed and
of course since it is a multi-class
classification problem for each inputs
you would provide to a chatbot it would
assign specific intent one of those that
you have in your training data so for
example if you asked in this example if
you ask something like I would like to
have a pizza it would still try to
assign one of those five interns here so
something to keep in mind and another
stage is entity extraction so entities
as I mentioned are pieces of information
that help a child but to make more
specific actions and to understand more
specifically what a user is asking so it
is a little bit more complicated a
process but in any way still quite
similar to intern classification so we
also use a tokenizer so we have two
tokenize input sentences into tokens and
usually it's can be something very
simple like a white space tokenizer and
then we use part of speech tagger which
assigns what is grammatical meaning of
the word so is it a verb is it a noun
adjective etc and we use chunker as well
and chunker creates like bigger chunks
of words for example and address it can
consist of more than just one word so
that's why we use chunk or as well and
then there is a named entity recognition
and entity extraction stage so for input
like what's the weather like tomorrow
the goal would be to extract the word
tomorrow as an entity so that it would
be used later on in later stages or
childhood
and action okay and how can you do it so
there are actually more than one way so
for example if you have a sentence like
this way you want to extract two
entities one entity is a cuisine for
burrito and another for location for an
address one of the examples could be
like very simple approach just use a
binary classifier where at first you
would predict if there is an entity in
the sentence at all and then on top of
that you would have another classifier
which would predict what entity that is
but what really works a lot better and
what is a lot that approaches direct
structured prediction so when we
actually look at each intent in the in
the sentence and then surrounding
intense like surrounding words have an
influence and have a prediction power on
that specific token that you're trying
to predict what it is what in that
intent that is sorry an entity that is
and for us I know you we use conditional
random fields and that works pretty well
so basically it looks at surrounding
words and sonic tokens and predicts what
what entity is the one that is a target
entity it works quite well and yeah it's
still not the most complicated I promise
you can take but of course you can
probably use some deep learning for that
as well
but I think it would require a lot more
training data okay so it's time to write
some code let's see so as I said I
really encourage you to follow along but
if you don't want to follow along you
can find all the code on github so I
have a repository which I hope you
haven't had enough time to get and
it has three main jupiter notebooks i
just want to point out quickly so i'm
going to use four as a workshop starter
so this is a code which is not
completely filled and i'm going to do an
right now and then if you want to just
see how the result is going to look like
you can use browser workshop completed
which has all code there and if you want
to see the results as well not only the
code you can try and use rasa workshop
completed executed because it has all
cells executed already and all the other
files that you see here they i will
explain them later on but they are
basically the outputs of some of the
commands we are going to use okay so we
are going to build a little chat but as
i mentioned and it's going to be a fun
chat but not nothing too complicated
we're going to build a childhood which
can check in about how the user feels
and then based on the answers make
specific actions so for example if you
feel super tired you can tell this
information to each other that's a good
question
I think that's the big is it better or
so the question was what is used for
entity extraction specifically so as I
mentioned conditional random fields is
the most popular approach so as I
mentioned it works really similar to
angry am so it looks for surrounding
words to predict what is the target word
a token is what kind of entity
conditional random fields so yeah as I
mentioned we are going to build a fun
little chat pods which will check in
about how the users feel and then will
take specific action based on the
answers so this entire workshop coding
workshop will go I will talk a little
bit about installation then we will
build a new model after that we will
build a dialogue management model and I
will share some resources to read after
and maybe share with some tips depending
on how much time I have cool so the
first stage is installation however I
heard that there are some issues with
Wi-Fi connection so I will not come to
do this stuff but basically I can just
walk you through so this one this cell I
can run so it's just a configuration for
a Jupiter it's not something related to
rather specifically I'm just
initializing some logging so that if
things go wrong I could check later on
where the errors were and also just a
little function which will help me to
print out the results a little bit nicer
okay so now the installation so as I
said I'm not going to do this just
because I want to avoid some connection
problems but I will just quickly explain
so we are going to use three main
libraries
rasa and aloo rasa core and spacing and
the spacer provides language model so
those be trained vectors which we can
use and trained rasa models with so
with this I'm just simply installing
Raza core and Raza
annal you and since we are using Spacey
it will install Spacey as well as part
of Raza and Alou and with these two
lines here I'm simply downloading the
Spacey English language model so the
back doors which I'm going to use and
just simply loading them in my
environment
okay and we should be able to check if
everything worked well so I'm just
checking which versions of Raza and Alou
and Raza core I have so I should have
Raza NLU 0.12 point three and razzaq or
zero point nine point six which is as it
is and also I should get some results
from the language model in this case I'm
just going to print hello world if
everything worked well and Spacey also
has a few different sizes of models and
those pre-trained factors so there is
like small model medium and large I
would suggest using medium large might
be too big depending on the domain
you're building your child was in and
small also might have not sufficient
vocabulary for your domain okay so yeah
I did got my hello world message so I
think everything is fine one another
tool which I'm going to use is graph
base and if you are doing things live
and if you get any errors with this
don't don't worry because graph is quite
stubborn library to install but I will
show you the results as I go so you
don't have to worry too much about that
okay let's start with our and all you
model so the first thing that we have to
do for any machine learning model to get
some training data for chatbots is it is
quite common question how do you get
training data in general because it's
not like some type of data that just
hangs around
so publicly on internet and it's
sometimes quite complicated to get any
data if you are building child for a
very specific domain and there are no
conversational data out there one of the
ways which i think is a good start is to
play a little game and pretend that you
are a child with yourself and then
either ask your friends or colleagues to
ask your questions for you to answer as
if you were a chocolate and just collect
some conversations like this and it
serves not only one purpose it also a
good way to validate the idea for your
childhood and also see the limitations
like if if some tasks are going to be
super super difficult for you
maybe it's it's a good food for thought
like how you would you know how your
child would go around those problems and
how to maybe simplify things and and so
on
so basically this is what I did and I
have three conversations which I'm going
to use as a basis to generate some
training data specifically for other NLU
because we will have to make some
changes in the format and write it in a
Raza Analia format as I mentioned for
Raza and Alou training data consists of
intense entities as labels and user
inputs as examples so what I will do now
is I will just go through those
conversations quickly and I will create
the intense which I'm going to use for
training of my childhood so I think I
will just keep it like this so that you
could see the conversations as well so
the conversation number two there is a
1-up as well but so a user started a
conversation saying hey so that means
that a user is greeting at a bot and for
this reason we have to specify an intent
for this in our training data so I will
create intent which I will call greet so
this is the mean
of either limits and now I will provide
an example of this input so it is going
to be hey okay so a chocolate responded
hello how are you doing and the user
said I'm very sad so it is not greeting
it is a user saying how they feel and
that's why I will create another intent
and I will call it maybe hmm mood
unhappy so a user feels unhappy and
again just simply providing an example I
am very sad
then I Travis's to cheer you up I can
show you a cute picture of a cat dog or
a bird then you can choose one and the
user says I would like to see a picture
of a kitten and this is a new intent
because it's not greeting it's not
saying that a user is unhappy it's just
providing a little bit more information
what a user would like to see the cheer
up so I will create another intent which
I will go just simply inform since it is
just providing a little bit more details
and just like with previous examples I
will provide this example and a choppa
said here is something to cheer you up
did that help and a user said yes now
now they feel happy so again it's not
reading I'm not saying that a user feels
unhappy or providing some information
and that's why we create another intent
which I've called affirm because it's a
user says yes yes Ana Shabbat said
goodbye and now just to illustrate
things a little bit more I will go
through conversation number three so a
user started the conversation with hair
it is greed
we already have an intern for this so
what we do we just simply add this as
another training example said hello how
are you doing and the user said not so
good and the only thing that could help
me feel better is a picture of a puppy
and we have an intern for this as well
so user says they don't feel really well
and it would go - as another example -
intent mood unhappy and then a bot said
here's something to cheer you up and did
that help and you said no they still
feel and have even seen pictures of
puppies and this is another intern
because we don't have intention for this
yet so I will simply create a new one I
will call this deny since it's just
simply saying no and here we'll go the
example and then a what said goodbye
user said bye and that is another intent
because we don't have intent for users
saying goodbye yet so I will just do
that users it so basically this is this
is how I'm generating training and
training data from scratch looks like
for Emily we have in terms which are the
labels and we have training examples as
text inputs one more thing that goes
into rasa NL you are entities so
entities are the question mm-hmm yeah
that's a really good question
so actually tablets for Chavez is quite
complicated like to extract more than
one intention from one sentence but of
course as humans we use really
complicated language and that's a really
good example so
and I'll use recently released a new
pipeline which is based on tensor flow
and it learns work vectors from scratch
and that enables identification of more
than one in 10 per sentence so it's like
and in this case and intent would be
like a combination of two tokens so you
could say that this example could also
be mood unhappy plus show me a picture
or something like that so yeah it was
released but recently I will show you
where you can read more about it later
on yeah so of course it's quite tedious
to write data by hand I would not
recommend to do that for big childhoods
there are some tools that you can use to
make it easier so rosin Aliyah also has
a UI which just makes all the process a
little bit easier but also other tools
like I think it's called chat Ito is
basically you can define what in terms
you want to have and what entities and
then you can just generate a bunch of
examples for and also you can define
what kind of information you would like
in those text examples and then it just
generates a bunch so I think that would
be best work around quickly
I think it's like that but that might be
just one T but you can drop me a message
after and I will look up and tell you
for sure okay so another thing that I
mentioned our entities and the pieces of
information that I for chavos would be
useful to know since it is a quite
simple example that we're using here I
can only see one specific entity so in
some examples we had that a user wants
to see a specific picture that would
make them feel better and this is
information that would help a child but
to share
an exact picture like of a puppy of a
cat of a burn and so on and we can train
the model to extract entities by simply
labeling them and our training data so
for example I have one example here so
when I user says the they are sad and
they would like to see a picture of a
puppy to feel better
so let's extract this end puppy world as
an entity and I do that by just adding
brackets and then I just simply provide
the name of this entity like how I want
to call it and I think I will call it a
group just what kind of group of
pictures a child should look for the
same for this example here so I have a
kitten so it is another training example
that a child could use to train entity
extraction so I just do the same I will
label and I will provide the name now
another thing people as I mentioned
speak in a complicated way and if we
would train the child were to only look
for cute pictures if we always just say
words specifically puppy or specifically
a kitten it would be super limiting
because some users would say oh I would
like to see a picture of a dog or I
would like to see a picture of a cat and
to go around this problem
razza and all you models have a feature
called the synonyms so basically you can
define what kind of other synonyms of
that specific part are out there so that
they would still be classified as one
specific group so how do we define
synonyms one of the ways is just to
simply provide the name to like what
kind of overall value of this intent
should be so for example here I have a
kitten and I can call this group cats so
if I would have another example where a
user said for example a picture
a cat good example so I would extract
this as an entity I will assign entity
name and then the value so the one that
will actually be extracted and it will
also be cat so that in this case like
kittens and cats and everything will be
extracted and the value of this entity
will be cats so that then you can use it
to make API calls you can use it to
retrieve data from database and it
basically generalizes a lot better and
thanks any questions about creating the
training data
yeah but since since it is
classification problem like there is a
specific label which you have to extract
and the entity value is that label that
is getting extracted so if you would you
would just have changing it out like
this it would still understand that for
example these two entities are entity
called group but the value is going to
be the exact value that it will find so
that's why you use synonyms cool so I
have just a very few example here and
it's definitely not going to be enough
just a question
yeah it should because of course you
don't have to when you create training
data for any machine learning model in
the end you are going to test on some
unseen training examples and of course
with sufficient amount of training data
it should be able to extract the entity
and the value of that word so as I
mentioned you need sufficient training
data so these few examples I have they
are not going to be enough and what I
have I have a little cheat that I'm
going to use and I just have a little
bit of more of training data examples so
the same intense that I defined but just
a little bit more possible ways of how
people would say these things and I'm
just going to simply provide this data
here so as you can see just a little bit
more examples of like saying that a user
want to see a picture of a dog or a cat
and so on or saying that people user is
unhappy and so on ok so now I'm going to
train the model and before I do that one
more thing is that is necessary is a
training pipeline pipeline defines how
those user inputs are processed and how
this information is expected so how we
tokenize sentences into words and and
and so on so I have the beginning of
this pipeline written here so as I said
I'm going to use a pre trained a spacing
model so that I would have vectors which
I could use to train the models for rasa
and I'm using NLP spacer model it's an
English model and then I'm defining what
tokenize I'm going to use so it just
simply splits the sentence into tokens
and the feature Iser also based on space
e which combines all those words vector
representations into sentence
representation and the classifier itself
which is going to be used and in this
case I'm going to use a PC SK learn
based
the SVM and a few more things which I
haven't included here so if you are also
doing entity extraction you should
specify this as well so that your model
would know that it should look for
entities as well so I'm just going to
quickly add those here so for entity
extraction I will use conditional random
fields which is called
CRF and also since we use synonyms it is
also necessary to tell your child that
there are synonyms and that a child
should extract words that are under the
same Sun on group as one specific value
so I will define this here and it is
called I think it is called there are
synonyms yeah so this is how the
pipeline go it looks like and the imp
attendances are going to go through all
these steps one after another like it's
not it's not really like that you have
to specify them in a specific order but
I can in how an aloo architecture is
cool and then we can train the model and
I'm going to run it it shouldn't take
too long because we don't have too many
training examples I'm just going to
quickly explain what's happening while
straining so first of all we are loading
training data so those examples that I
have written previously and then I'm
just simply initializing the trainer
which will take care of training the
model and we have to provide
configuration file so that a model like
would know how to parse incoming
messages from a user and then I'm simply
calling train function which trains the
model and I save the model in specific
location where I want you so this path
can be any type of path where you want
to keep your model and I
specify a fixed model name so that it
would be easier later to find what the
model is and to feature it easier cool
the training finished so it's really
small model so yeah I think yeah it did
just 12 fits and when we train the model
what we want to do of course we want to
test so I can do that by using
interpreter parse method from rossignol
you and I can provide an input user
input that I would like to test my
chocolate on so let's try I will just
say I was try hi let's see if that works
okay so these are the results of the
model and prediction so the first thing
we can see is intense and in turn
classification results so a chatbot
things using a know your model that
saying hi is grid which is correct and
you can also get the confidence level
like how confident the chocolate was
about the specific prediction
it would also have any entities if we if
we if it found any it didn't and also we
have confidence levels for all the other
interns that we have in our training
data i will try another one something
with entities i will try
show me a picture of a so yeah so it
thinks that it is unhappy but i think it
redic mood unhappy because of those like
examples when i had that a user said i'm
unhappy but just show me a picture of a
dog and i will feel that and we can see
an entity i will explain why it is she
was instead of some kind of dog group
its it is for an api but basically yeah
so this is an
entity which should be a dog because you
can also see that start and end symbols
are from 23 to 26 so it's three three
characters so it's definitely definitely
a dog extracted as an entity and it just
has a value which I assigned in my
training examples for this synonym
so we use use taste for a dialogue
management for for NLU it's just like
what kind of training data you have and
basically that that's what it uses to
make predictions okay so this is our
training model and before I move on to
the next stage I am going to talk a
little bit about dialogue management
unless you have any more questions about
things I showed okay so yeah so we have
our model a childhood understands what I
say that's great okay let's see what's
next
so about management and how it happens
and what is under the hood so first of
all why would you want to use dialogue
management rather or using R as a core
and machine learning in general for
dialogue management so it allows you to
ditch state machines so by state
machines I mean when you use some kind
of rule-based approach and create a
happy path or probably one more than one
just one happy path but still you kind
of predefined the journey that a user
would take when it talks to a childhood
and the sense
razza core is using by a machine
learning and it's learning from data you
don't need to predefined any rules at
all it picks up patterns from training
data that you provide so I have built
some childhoods using state machines and
it is a nightmare
it's easy like it's easy when you have a
really simple bot but when you try to
build something a little bit more
complicated and more scalable it's just
really really big hassle to go through
all the rules and try to find the place
where this new roof would fit in also
some approaches are using reinforced
reinforcement learning so like learning
from user feedback but the problem with
reinforcement learning is that it
requires a lot of data to train at first
and with
quite a challenge to get a lot of
training data and also it's quite
difficult to define a good reward
function so that it would learn correct
things and yeah and it's it's not really
too complicated to use Roszak or even if
you don't know Python there is a way to
use Razzak or you can use HTTP request
and you can use Raziq or with any other
language you want so those actions that
are predicted they might be executed in
any other programming language so it
just makes things a lot easier and yeah
so I mentioned why machine learning is
that it picks up things from the data
and not from predefined rule sets of how
a child should respond at specific stage
of the conversation so as you can see
there are so many different ways how a
conversation could start and go so a
user could say goodbye a user can say
you can say thank you or greet and using
state machine or rule-based approach you
would have to implement a rule for for
each of them and use a machine learning
you provide training data and it accept
those patterns from from training data
itself yeah so if you're trying to build
a more complicated about using state
machines it basically turns into
something like this I'm pretty sure this
this is a representation of quite simple
talk about using state machines I think
it can do just a few things but it's
yeah I think that the table that I was
building myself looked quite similar
state machines okay so however as a core
works and how it does all this machine
learning magic so from an ally model it
took another model extracts structured
data from user inputs of intents and
entities and they go to but they are
combined with the specific state like
where the conversation is and they are
used to also rather call looks at
previous actions so like
what a child would did before and what
was previous state and it uses this
information to predict the next action
how does the prediction so it can be
also an SVM or it can be a recurrent
neural network and yeah and then when it
makes a prediction this new state that
got predicted it becomes an updated
state which is then probably combined
with some kind of API call or like
retrieving data from the database and a
child but simply makes a response okay
and a little bit deeper look into rather
core architecture and how things work so
in resin Allu stage we perform in
Tangela fication and entity extraction
details and they are fed into recurrent
neural network and alongside interns and
entities that were extracted from this
input for something what's the weather
like tomorrow
using Raza and Lu model we have
additional details so they can be API
calls or entity outputs so like what
kind of additional leaders were provided
by a chatbot and also it is using
previous conversations to make
predictions for the next ones yeah so I
would just want to think as I said
browser core model is using previous
conversations as well and that's why I
said recurrent neural network so at
first it gets previous conversations and
then it gets current state and that's
why it works as a recurrent neural
network another thing that you might
want to have is an action mask so for
example you would like to limit your
childhood at some specific stage to not
perform some specific actions for
example to limit the performance for
specific clients or something like
and you can use action masks it is not
yet implemented specifically for a
Sakura but there is a lot of research
done I'm pretty sure it is mentioned and
looked into in the paper that Rosser was
working on recently so hopefully quite
soon is going to be implemented as a
core as well for you to use and once
it's done all the probabilities are
renormalized so that a child could go
back to an actual regular performance of
being able to predict all the actions
that were in training data and so when
the predictions are finished there is a
sample action which is produced what a
child thinks it should do next
and it is combined with some specific
actual action so making an API call or
just providing a text response and etc
one very important thing is that all the
cycle here it doesn't have to be just
like one one thing and like it doesn't
have to run only once per user input so
there can be one user input and can be
like five different actions that a child
but it performs subsequently so it
really just depends on the state of the
conversation and and the domain and so
on yeah and then it provides an answer
it will be sunny and 20 degrees Celsius
yeah
so with action masks you can limit your
child limit the amount of actions that
your child can perform so in your
training data you would probably define
for example five actions but at specific
state of conversation or for a specific
domain you would like to limit your
child so that if food would be able to
predict only three so you can use action
mask for that and since you are
excluding some of the actions you have
to renormalize prediction so that they
would sum up to one again and that it
will just work as it should be okay time
to code again so I'm going to get back
to the Jupiter notebook why I left it
and we are going to build a dialog
management model or one thing that I
forgot to mention about Randall you and
it will apply to razor core as well is
that you can use also you can evaluate
your models so this code right here it
will load the model and it will deform
like kind of like a cross-validation
like how how how good the predictions
are depending on your training data of
course you should define some testing
and training data for this you shouldn't
really test on your training data so I
think I should get results here in a
second okay yeah so basically provides
precision recall app score for each of
the intense we had in our training data
and confusion matrix which basically
shows how many times
goodbye intent was predicted when it had
to but again I'm doing this on my
training data something that you should
never do okay
dialog management and so I will start
with training examples again but I'm
just going to quickly show you how to do
that I'm not going to spend
so too much time because I have some
more exciting things to show you as well
so in Raza core training data consists
of stories and a story is a
representation of an actual conversation
that a user would have the chat and user
inputs are extracted in a in a way of
intense and entities like combination of
intense and entities and responses of a
child both are expressed as actions that
a child would make at the specific state
of the conversation so one of the
examples could be I will just write one
so for example Story number one so this
is just basically providing the name to
the story it's just for debugging but it
just makes it easier to look at things
later on so for example I can write one
story where a user said for example
hello that would correspond to intent
greet and I'm going to just going to
simply provide this intent that a user
greeted a child and then a child would
respond with probably something like hey
how are you feeling today and it would
this response should be written as an
action that I traveled would make so I
could write it as for example utterance
[Music]
for example greet as well so you say
hello rapid I said hello how can how are
you feeling today and then let's say a
user said I am feeling sad and again we
have to provide the intent that would be
assigned to this input and in my
examples I think it was mood unhappy and
just to show you one more thing so if
you have a so let's say that a user said
I'm feeling very sad and please show me
a picture of a puppy so if you have
entities that you want to be extracted
from a train
you should also specify them in your
stories so I will just simply going to
do that by providing I think I called
the group so it is the name of the
entity and then the value that was
extracted so let's say it was a cat or a
dog and then let's say a user sorry HR
but looked up the picture for for this
for a cat and it should also be
expressed as an action so it could be
let's say action find picture and as I
said that can be more than one action
for user input so I chat bot could find
a picture and it could also ask
something else like did it help for
example so it could be also like
utterance let's say better like do you
feel better and then a user would
respond with something so maybe they
said yes I feel better now so then I
would again provide intent that
corresponds to this input so it would
probably be a firm if I remember
correctly from my examples that I gave
previously and probably a chatbot would
respond something and like maybe goodbye
like you are happy now so let's say
utterance goodbye so basically this is
how the training data generation looks
like and we have some questions mm-hmm
sorry can you
yeah it should be it should be cats Oh
so as I said the health management model
looks at quite a few pieces on from
information to make predictions so it
looks at intents that are extracted from
user input entities so that's why we
specify this entity right here also
looks at previous actions and so on so
for training data and for the purposes
of training the model so that it would
know what specifics it should look at it
should know that here this entity will
be expected as well ok so again this is
the same situation as with an igloo
one story is definitely not going to
build good chatbot so we need more to
build simple child bus you don't need
huge amounts of training data so for
example here I have a little bit more of
training examples I was like like seven
training stories like seven possible way
is seven possible ways of how a child
could speak to a user could speak to a
childhood so I'm just going to add them
here so that I would train a little bit
better model but basically as you can
see the same thing repeats conversation
throughout after conversation so you
have one story which represents an
actual conversation a user would have
the chat but another one and and so on
and of course to build a chat which
scales you should include quite wide
range of training examples so if you if
all of the stories will be like in 10
greet and then action utterance greet
and then and they will repeat all the
things again and again your child will
learn just to make predictions like for
the same things but if you want to build
a scalable child but you should think of
what other situations a user could end
up with so for example saying no instead
of years at specific situations and so
on what do you mean by nesting
oh yeah absolutely
so yeah I think I would just take some
of those and just create more
complicated ones with more turns and so
on yeah okay I'm going to save this and
the next stage for diode management
model when you have training data is
defining a domain domain defines the
universe where a child lives and in the
world of a chatbot this universe
consists of details that it would be
ready to see and act on so for example
it should be aware of intense it should
be seeing also what entities so the ones
we defined in the training data also
what actions it should make again the
same ones we had in our stories and
another thing that we can provide our
the templates and those templates
correspond to possible actions a child
could make one specific action is
predicted so for example when a trans
grid action a trans grid is going to be
predicted here we can define what kind
of message it will be sent back to the
user so for example here a child will
say hey how are you
or when a user says that they are happy
and an action if it is predicted that a
child should respond with utterance
happy it will say great carry on
important thing you can define more than
one a possible action so it doesn't have
to be one response over and over again
and you can do this simply by just
writing more examples here so for
example there are other possible ways
how a user could say sorry a chopper
could say hey so for example I would
just write another one say hello
oh how are you doing today or something
like that and it can be five it can be
ten it can be 20 if you want and then
when the prediction is made they will be
randomized and it just really helps to
make chatbots which are capable of being
more interesting and not repeating
themselves over and over again okay so
I'm going to save this right now one
thing as well related to domain and
responses that a child uses so it
doesn't have to be only text responses
all the time as I mentioned it can be an
API call or it can be like retrieving
data from the database and since they
are a little bit more complicated action
so we can define them by creating custom
actions so I'm going to quickly show you
how to do one
so this custom action is going to make
an API call to retrieve an actual
picture of a cat or a dog or a bird and
I'm going to use a like live API for
this so just quickly going to explain
what's happening here so custom action
consists of two main functions one which
defines the name of the action that a
childhood will see and the one will be
predicted so for example this action
retrieve image is going should be
included in training examples if it
should be predicted at some point and
another function which is the body of of
things that are going to happen when
this action is predicted and yeah
so one thing so this API call should be
made for specific type of animal and a
dog or a cat or a bird and how my child
will know that so if you remember we
defined entities for that so probably
cats or dogs actually she was going to
be extracted as an entity and I can save
this Val
you and make my childhood to remember
what I asked and just keep it like in a
in a context so that whenever in in
specific state of the conversation when
a user asks for this a child just
remembers and knows which specific group
it should make this API call and we can
save them like those values of the
entities by filling in the slots and
it's the one thing that I actually
didn't do quite yet so it slots as I
mentioned they simply save pieces of
information that a child should remember
as the conversation goes and so that it
would be able to go back and reach you
those details so I'm going to define
them right here so slots and what I have
to do I have to provide the name of that
piece of information that I want to keep
track of so since I want to my trouble
to remember what is the group the entity
that was extracted I will simply provide
it here and another thing that is
important is to define the type of the
slot and different types of lots of
slots have different influence on how
the prediction is made so I'm going to
specify a slot type text and when type
is text whether or not this lot is
populated so if this entity is extracted
and saved it's going to influence their
prediction of the next action there are
other possible slot types if you want
your child were to completely ignore
like the fact if the slot is populated
or not you can specify it as an feature
and feature eyes and so on but you also
have to keep in mind like what kind of
slots you are specifying okay and then
when you when you save your slots what
you have to do what you can do is to
retrieve them in a
specific actions so here I'm going to do
that because I don't need the value of
this slot to make a correct API call and
tracker and Massacre is responsible for
keeping it a track of populated slots so
I'm going to call the tracker and I
think it's called get slot function
which will retrieve the value of the
slot that I'm interested in and the slot
name was and then once this gets slot
method is executed the extracted value
of a slot is going to be populated in
this variable so what I'm going to do
now I'm going to just simply define an
API call which I don't remember by heart
so I will use requests and here I'm
simply defining what API call should be
used here so it's a publicly available
API you don't need any keys or any
authentication for this and here where I
will have a value of what kind of like
is it a cat is it a dog is the bird that
this API should retrieve the picture of
and there are some additional features
of this API call so how many pictures
you want I will ask for only one and so
I will just simply retrieve a URL of
this and I will also ask for HTTP URLs
so you can use any API here like it it
doesn't have to be the specific one and
since I have this valet slot and a
placeholder for a variable that I could
use so I will provide the value of my
slot which is group
and then so this will return the JSON
which I have to extract and get the
deals that I'm only interested in so I
had to do a little bit of cleansing for
this URL to look nicely and dispatcher
for Roszak or custom actions is
responding not only custom action but in
for any action is responsible for
sending out the messages and here I can
specify how a user HR bot will respond
so I will say here is something to cheer
you up
so this is how the custom action would
look like again it can be something else
retrieving data from the database and
you just define like connecting to the
database and retrieving data using slots
or not using slots depends on how you
want your child to behave and I'm going
to save this and since it is a custom
action my child should know that this
action exists so I'm going to go back to
the domain and in the actions list I
will add this and this is in main
since I'm using the Jupiter notebook and
this class for this custom action was
called API action
okay so I'm going to save this now and I
will try to if you want you can of
course I'm just going to receive a URL
which I'm going to click on and another
in the thing before I train is you can
visualize the training data and see how
the stories look like so if the graph
base is going to work for me hopefully I
will have a nice picture of my training
examples so basically that's like the
structure and and how the conversations
could go based on the training data that
we have so for example a user could say
hi at first and then a child would
respond with a trans greet or a user
could say something about how they are
feeling immediately without saying hey
or something like that and and then the
Shabbat would respond so it's a really
good way to inspect your data and and
see if something doesn't really make
sense because of course to build a good
training model you have to use good
straining data so you can eliminate
something that doesn't really help your
childhood to perform better
I mean if so the question was if some
data is not extracted how to make sure
that a child can continue
mmm-hmm so one of the ways you can do
that is to use interactive learning so
it's another feature of Raza core and
this is how you can actually see what
exactly a ciabatta extracted or not and
then to fix some of the mistakes
yourself and then those Corrections that
you make are picked up by by a child bot
and it is using later on I think you can
also implement some kind of check in
your one of the custom actions probably
as well to check if this value is
populated or not and then if not a child
a child would make specific response
like hey I need some more information
cool so now I'm going to train the model
it'll probably take a few seconds as
well
and what I'm going to do I'm just going
to walk you through what's happening so
I'm going to use of course the training
data the training data but I'm going to
use the domain that I defined so all the
interns and entities and and actions
that my child should know about and the
policies that should be used to train
the model and Raza has quite a few
policies which you can use yeah it
depends depends on the situation and
then I just load my training data and
three in the model and you can see that
you can specify the parameters for
training as well so to just test the
performance if if something doesn't make
doesn't work well you can tune those
parameters as well so I'm here I'm just
simply providing the training data that
I used and validation split so what
percentage of your training examples
should be used for testing and also the
number of epochs so how many passes of
your data should be done during the
training so since I have a really small
data sample I'm going to use 200 which
is the thing relatively high so what it
is doing its
simply training the model and running
epoch after epoch and it finished yeah
and it the model was saved and now the
exciting part I'm going to give it a go
and see how the chatbot behaves so to do
that I have to load my model and I'm
using agent dot load method here and I'm
loading the model without management
model which I just trained and as well I
will need an interpreter which I have to
specify so that my bot would know what
is going to be used to understand what
the user said so I'm using my Anna Lou
model which I trained previously that
you can also use other interpreters if
you want so in some cases for example
reg X might work pretty well depends
okay and now let's give it a try yeah so
interpreter is a model or a framework
that you're using to parse incoming
messages from a user so I built an early
model previously and it's going to be my
interpreter but you can also use other
interpreters if you if you like yeah so
for example now I will start speaking
with my boss and I will say something
and it will be passed to the interpreter
the Nou model and it will extract
intense and entities and and will use
them
ok let's see so I would say say hello
and a table would responded with hey how
can I help you which means that an
action greeting was predicted ok I will
say I am very sad and Chavez said to
cheer up I can show you a cute picture
of a dog a cat a bird and which one do
you choose
so an action check in on the mood was
predicted and ok let's try
we'll see I want to see a picture of a
puppy so just thinking okay um okay
no no that didn't help me okay but I see
that it is I either made a typo in my
HTTP request or is it just simply not
having connection yeah yeah so
unfortunately yeah that doesn't help me
at all okay so I chose it by I can give
it a try but I don't have much hope say
hey yeah yeah I am
really bad
okay yeah it didn't look too promising
so okay so unfortunately I can't show
because of the network problems but in
the code that I provided you can
definitely test it out okay so and then
if I want to stop the conversation I
will just do stop and also you can
evaluate your model just like you're an
ally model so get the same evaluation
matrix for actions that it had and how
it predicted cool I have not too much
time left
okay so okay so I have some actions
there which are not getting responses
because of the natural problems as well
so mmm great so basically you would have
matrix just like I showed you for NLU
but it would be for actions yeah so
something like this but instead of
intense that would be actual actions
that add in the dialogue management
model was predicting okay um so I have
only seven minutes left so I'm just
gonna go back and just talk about you
other things that I would like to
mention I didn't have a chance to I
don't think I have enough time to show
you online training so the one that I
mentioned that you can actually correct
your childhood as you talked it so it's
called in online learning or interactive
learning so you simply train your model
as well but you see what predictions a
child made as it goes what intensity
extracted what entities and what action
it is about to execute like what action
is predicted and then you can just tell
no you're wrong and you should actually
make this action instead or that this
different intent should have been
classified and then a child would
pick up those Corrections so yeah if the
behavior is wrong you can just simply
correct them and it would retain the
model and it is also a good way to
generate some training data because you
can then extract those correct
conversations and append them to your
training examples so now we are not
going to go because I'm running out of
time and so the research that Raza is
working on so one of the things that I
mentioned previously for one of the
questions there is a new rasa
you know utensil for pipeline which
learns word embeddings from scratch
rather than using pre train involved
vectors and it is more flexible approach
because you can build Chavez for more
specifically main since you're not using
preacher in vectors you are less likely
to bump into the problems of
insufficient vocabulary and things like
that and you can also build chat BOTS in
most of the languages I am I'm not I'm
not saying any languages because we
didn't test them all but most of the
languages you would like your childhood
to speak and also it can identify a
multi intense so that one user input can
actually mean more than one thing
and we wrote quite a few blog posts and
actual tutorials on that so if you're
interested go check them out using those
links I think it would be like another
session on this specific thing only so
here is an example of those multi
intents so that you would have example
like hey how are you and something I
don't really care and then you would
assign a multi intend greet and don't
care to this and it can't complicate
things a little bit more so you have to
be careful with using things like you
have to use them only when it really
makes sense because I think it's quite
an easy way to over complicate your
childhood but on the flip side it can
when used well it can make child bus a
lot more flexible and generalizable
another thing that Roz is working on is
generalizing dialogues across tasks
across different domains so that it can
learn actions and and states but it
should go into when you have training
data from for example things related to
hotels and then things related to
restaurant requests and then you can
combine them and build child bus which
can operate in more than one domain and
share this training data and before I
finish just the final thoughts so of
course as with any probably and machine
learning problem the goal is to actually
get some training data make that data in
the correct format and then get some
feedback and see how it performs and
then make improvements and between your
model and use improve model in the end
and if you are interested in
contributing to open source you are
definitely more than welcome to do so
some of the possible challenges you can
work on so for example how to handle out
of vocabulary words because with
pre-trained for vectors some some of the
words may not be detected and also if
you have some really rare words or some
very specific distinct domain that's
also quite common problem multi language
entity recognition and so browsing is
working on that side as well not only
for intense but for entities as well but
your input would also be available here
and combination of dialog models so how
we can combine more than one to two to
create great models and some readings
for your research for your raining day
and things that maybe you would find
interesting so for example this star
space embeddings is the paper that new
residents of a pipeline was based on and
got some inspiration so definitely check
them out
so all these links are also in the
slides which I will definitely share
after
and summary so it's always best to start
small and have some training data to get
started and the one tip that I'm going
to definitely share with you that I
think it's best to start with some small
data set for training build your bot and
then let people use it and collect more
training examples and then use them as
like boost for your training data
because they are going to reflect real
conversations a lot more than just you
yourself like sitting and thinking of
possible ways of how people could
interact with your childhood and as I
said you can definitely combine rosanna
luan and rather core with other
different languages so I showed API call
in Python but you can do this in
different languages as well it's just
simply using an HTTP request and yeah
with using resin alien machine learning
and rahzar core you are abandoning full
chart so you are learning patterns of
conversations from an actual data rather
than defining specific rules so we are
give it a try and build some great
childhoods and just a very quick
and the very quick heads up get in touch
if you have any questions I'm more than
happy to help you out and we are hiring
we are looking for machine learning
project success engineers and machine
learning engineers if you want to work
on open source and conversational AI get
in touch